little it all
Dada but the pepper pepper pepper pepper
we shall continue our adventure today
rest alright let's start this one uh
double dipper scream I love my horse but
help the scientists start a food chain
first create an energy source for life
and supernovae Oh [ __ ] that work
what's up what's up
holy [ __ ] a mix volcanoes erupt and
Willy died poor Willy or inside your
real name Willy now create life form at
the bottom of the food chain that can
use that energy what's on the bottom
like al al geez
alby's go out this I Love You Man God
squid wow it's awesome I didn't know
squid was so awesome plankton
yes kailia smooch selects again oh my
god I'm so smart
no they ate Willy Willy what are you
doing dance now create a Victorian
animal in the food chain to feed on the
aquatic plants ah what about Willy
he totally ate them well um what comes
after plankton
squid squid a goat squid it ate the
matches eat them [ __ ] squid are you
terrible why do you look so weird
squiddy
can I write this quitting I think Gabe
you can tiny fish gasps you wouldn't
think I did yeah no II did not show that
yes yes okay okay what's next
finally create a predator at the top of
them shark is shoe how about that shaky
shoe eat them [ __ ] fine what and
whacked our Jade is dedicated to do did
it did it did it
I got 46 what's up Mike raka crew and I
will continue our journey what do you
need my friend nothing what do you need
my friend come closer to stop another
challenger I have never a a crea scape
from a challenge
sorry about that
I don't know what's wrong with me today
holy [ __ ] I'm head banging like a [ __ ]
we're on the submarine Toro the first
stop in the shipwreck creates three
objects that you would find in a
shipwreck treasure
yes indeed stretch ah quite splendid put
your there you would find skeletons yes
indeed skeletons quite splendid yes yes
I'm gonna roll here you would find a
flag yes indeed yes indeed
what's that it we all live in orange now
the tourists want to see the okay create
too dangerous sea creatures giant evil
squid is able is able and it's drug to
giant evil squared what aa giant evil
squid I would pretend I didn't say that
or you you're dead now how about khatola
I would be pretty [ __ ] scared [ __ ] it
if swim so dashingly I think Russ yes I
know it I mean like such a splendid
creature with us beautiful moment my
ayah sharking column fight fine swim
together and be gay in shed okay whoa
ascetic turtles where's the Yellow
Submarine now create you objects that
onward battle scene that it will astound
the toilet a battle a battle that shall
be a battle Indy giant octopus
yes I see Janice what fun toys their
minds to use minds I forget I'm so
stupid
yeah yeah I just kill each other I don't
give a [ __ ] turtle doesn't care anything
now we're right at the ruins of an
ancient lost city although it looks a
little plain crazy ancients objects to
impress - [ __ ] tourists where are
they anyway
I already made all of them yes I [ __ ]
rule
give me that [ __ ] give me that [ __ ] oh
underseater completed that data but die
by badda-badda badda-badda there we go
bras name as probably us as one would
say in Swedish dead ur dead urdead look
at that fat ass what's up I'm so hungry
this machine is empty will this change
it to fall on Michelle it's fall yeah no
well that's just [ __ ] give me food
now yet what do you want I could earn
some money if I learn some skills
carotid teacher I can because the
teacher what the [ __ ] alright what do
you I I'd better clean up these titles
yeah you better do it oh you want a
broom that's it
dead dead dead dead dead and I go down
and down
what do you want old lady I'm tired of
standing well how about a wheelchair
excuse me badass wheelchair hey what are
you doing one more one more
everyone in line gentlemen you don't
want anything well if you want something
I want to buy something from the stand
but I'm broke a pressure present for a
pretty lady she's a lesbian that's
wonderful
well what the [ __ ] are you guys doing
alright hopefully the last Street Rock
start he wants to be a rock star first
he needs an instrument how about a
didgeridoo most badass instrument of the
mount horror this is really awesome but
my band would sound a lot better with
additional members a band
what are you fighting
but this [ __ ] now this is what I call a
band but we need equipment foot but a
real a drum set
I'll do the drum set are you tired ah a
float a saxophone okay I did it
yeah it's a party that's a [ __ ]
party that's my star said one more bras
one [ __ ] more Jesus I get I get a lot
did it it did it
da-da-da-da-da-da help the students win
science fair can't wait can't [ __ ]
wait and animal science over a little Oh
first give the Paramecium source of
nutrition loot Tony I don't [ __ ] know
oh that worked
it needs some heat jadvyga a fire
launcher a flamethrower that's what I
call there we go
Wow it's starting to grow next I should
give it something I creatures body which
Britain all right we finally have 50 yes
oh [ __ ] she's hideous
ah poor Lily man little look what I got
you look really ugly and the rocket ship
crashes hey I know your sister's dying
and all but let's go to space [ __ ] yeah
space why the [ __ ] not
what is that a lipstick oh it's a wrong
why you have any not created myself a
jetpack before how could I be so blind
da da da da da da Dan alright so it's
the last level let's try and finish it
thank you for watching this episode AB
Scribblenauts and then that next one
will unfortunately be the last one makes
me a little sad but hey I am riding on a
space cow [ __ ] spread cow away
one flag babe screamed like a little
girl